Hello everybody my name is markiplier and welcome to night lights. Now Night Lights is an adorable game with a very very unique
Game mechanic that I've actually never seen before. I saw a very,
Oh that's so cool.
Wait no this just showed it okay, so notice how there's no gap there. I can't go down this ladder, right
I'm mashing the button, and I do nothing okay, so you hit that and it turns on that light. And then suddenly
The path opens before you because the lights in this game or at least some of the lights,
Remove like they just remove material
and I'm not sure what kind of metaphysical bullshit is going on to make that happen but
suddenly
It's here, and it's solid.
I mean, I'm sure someone will come up with a lore explanation of why this is happening.
And how this could possibly be good for the universe, just lights absolutely destroying anything
And then it just reappearing. What if like, someone, was actually affected by this light and they're
Just like "aah my lower half where did it go!"
And it just reappeared later. Ugh, okay, where am I going? Oh, I know it
I'm gonna is this thing just gonna rise magically out of the ground? Please tell me it will,
Oh god, how uncomfortable for that to be stuck permanently underground like that. Can you imagine - that was a person?
Just aah help me, somebody do something.
Okay wait what am I doing here?
Wait what am I, why didn't it? Yeah? What happens to me. Let's just. This is my skeleton actually
I'm like 90% bone here.
Alright okay alright, see ya!
Oh we got rid of a wall!
Wait was there a wall in the way? probably, okay. What is where is this leading me? Okay, all right I'm going.
Mmm nice. Oh, it's so cool. Oh. It's so cool. I love the art style! ooh
Look at that look it, hello Hootie. What you hooting about over there?
Stop hooting at me, I'm trying to solve puzzles x + bluhh... ah. ahhhhh... ohhhh...
Yee?
Ok so I know what I gotta do, a little bit.
I gotta create a path by which I can get this box out of there,
maybe
Probably. Aaah I can climb!
I'm like Mario!
Oh
That's so nice. Well the box is gone,
the box is just plain old gone alright. I see how you work. Ok. I see. I see what's going on here.
Ok alright, so it just slips into another dimension that's so weird. *Laughs*
I mean, I know there's a trick with like layers, and the such as like, but still that's that's pretty darn cool. That's you
gotta give it credit as pretty darn cool. Ok so
I got a token I think?
What does it even do for me? Oh I got a flame! Oh, I put the flame in the box.
Oh look at that and it powers
thats so cool! Did I build all this by the way? That's another thing that I have kind of a conundrum about.
Oh the music's cool too!
This whole game's cool! Oh, oh well
Well, this is a, is a decision I gotta make. Oh, I gotta go get it first and then do the things. Oh this is so nice.
So it's night, and it's lovely oh gosh. Do I take fall damage? Good
this is like it's so lovely and I fall and break my shins, ow
The jagged bones are so lovely. Alright where am I going here? I'm gonna put this in this box cuz that's gonna go
Ooh where are you going? Wait come back wait! No hang on! I need I think I need you! I
think aaah,
Jiminy Christmas where'd you go? Oh? You're coming back ok I gotta hurry, aah sorry
I thought that maybe, I thought that maybe that maybe you were gonna be gone forever. I'm like a dog
I just think once you leave like you're gone permanently and I'm like,
ah no, I'm so sad. Oh, I could have put something in here.
All righty, then interesting well that box should have dropped down.
Okay, hi camera there you are. All right
So this box is here, but how do I get this box up that goddamn hill? Now that
That is a question, that is an interesting question.
Ooo wait a minute! Oh I saw I saw
Whoa this is uh quite a box, I saw something oh, I saw something. Oh, uh-huh oh ho ho
Indeed uh Oh No Oh, I'm coming with you! Yes yes
that's amazing!
Aaah okay keep going, Oh, so close all right cool cool. Cool cool. What about that other thing up there?
I don't have two of those things. I don't have two things so I gotta go here?
All right was that like a bonus level?
Okay, all right I'm gone then okay.
That's
lovely Oh goodbye material world. Oh look at the way, it's scooches
oh
It's scooches is so goosh. This reminds me actually have another game that I played I can't remember what it was called
It was kind of some kind of like zombie game where you actually control
the plague. Night Terror or something like that.
I can't remember what it was, I played it a while back not like a while while back, but some while back
yeah. Anyway, just like the art style this is kind of familiar to me. Uh god, why didn't I bring the goddamn, box? I'm a fool.
That's why, now you go in oh?
Are those doors like powered now or something? Okay, all right then. Oh?
skooshy, jumpy
Climbey. All right. Is this gonna go up?
Better go up. Huh it goes up all right.
I don't know why those doors are powered they're like inverse five nights at Freddy's doors
They only stay open when they're powered or no, they
I don't even think, whatever
Wait didn't I just come through that portal? Didn't I just come
through that portal? Why do I gotta go back through that portal again? Why do wha do I gotta? oh?
I don't think I need that box anymore. Oh what I okay. I'm gonna be entombed well. Please okay, so I take this thing
Can I take you? I'll get you I'll get you
Imma gonna get you in a second there. Okay, alright, okay, so where is this all leading me? Also beautiful  place,
I'd like to think that this is the forest from Firewatch.
Hmm and just somewhere else somewhere else in this area, there's this just a guy having a,
having a troubling conversation via the radio, which is what Firewatch was all about. Hello!
Hi, what are you doing? Here? How do I get up you?
Mmm. Okay
I see I see what's going on here
Huh I see my big beefy brain can put two and two together to know that I'm gonna go
Ah, no, please, please, ah, ah
Ok well that didn't work out, but now that I got a power dudy. I can put this over
Ooo is that gonna land on my head and crush me? Gosh!
Yay, blonk. Oh well. I got minor blane dabbleage
C to pull? Thank you for that tutorial! That is a well timed tutorial cuz otherwise... Well it
Yes, um I'm seeing real hard. Ah there now it works. It wasn't
No, I want to pull it pull.
Grab, pull.
Alright, you better not stop
Cuz I'm
pullin. I'm whangin. I was whangdoodlin that C as hard as I could whangdoodle it. Now it needs to
cooperate with me
aaaaand
GO, GO, GO, GO, GO, GO!
alright, aaaaand
GO, GO, GO, GO, GO!
Alright got it nailed it. Hey. It doesn't need to be flat. This ain't Human Fall Flat. This is box land all crooked.
Clunk, it no work
Conundrumness. Oh okay. All right. Well. No! Oh wait. No that's correct. I don't know why I panic so much about that.
Diddly dee de deedle
I'm floating in the sky, okay, so what happens if I break it? What happens if I just keep this here?
What happens if I stand on this and squoosh myself? Am I gonna get squooshed?
OWWWWW!
Apparently not, okay, never mind that was
that was uhh...
Anticlimactic. What does this do? Anything? A door?
What that oh?
Squoosh me squoosh me now, okay?
Okay, all right. I see how you do. These aren't exactly complex puzzles,
but they feel satisfying because I feel good about myself. Also the landscape in the background
That background is ah it's good. Look at that sweet parallax scrolling, I love it. Wait I shouldn't have been on here
no, no, no I
da I'm an idiot
gah, ah, I went through it again!
I'm so stupid let me use my big brain. I'm gonna jump on his platform that down
I wonder why it didn't work before when I was over there
Totally forgot why. Okay so once I get up here
I put the box on the I know you all understand this, but I'm explaining for my own benefit so I don't forget again.
I put the box over on the thing no oh damn it
Oh, it's too late. Alright, and then... that's all I got to do right?
I think so I'm not 100% sure but I think so. My big brain is telling me yeppers. I
Always trust my big brain when it tells me yeppers, wait oh!
I didn't think that was gonna work. I thought that needed a flame thing.
Love the way the music is pulsing, boom!
Okay, so whoa
what in the hell is that?
Music stopped!
Mr. Orchestra man, you could kick it up any time now!
It's a little weird being alone in this...
dungeon!
Okay, well bye okay, I guess. See ya. Well, I'll stay here forever then.
I don't know if I trust you, magic portal.
Underneath what could be a poop vent, but here we go whaa it's a poop vent!
It's  a death cannon! Oh!
It's last chance or one shot, it's one shot, one sh... one light one shot, which I need to finish.
Ah my brain, ah god
that went into my brain! Oow!
I have the power.
Oh, I have the power! Look at me! Whoa.
Whoooooooooaaahhh *dissolves into laughter*
All right now, I got a really think about this. Okay, all right, so that turned that off. This
That that that not good to be like that. Okay, so this go der. Dis, I pull you here.
No, no I'm gonna push you apparently. Not apparently like
There all right don't worry my big brain has been intercepted by a light bulb
It's kind of hard to conundrumalate. Why didn't that fall? Hey! Shift.
Fall! Oh, it's the wrong block.
Will this block fall?
Shift
Ayyyyy, uh ayyyy, OW ayyyy.
Okay, alright. (x2)
Shift. Aww, I thought I was gonna take a shortcut. So it's a matter of finding out which material
Is the right material to be able to pass through.
That's fascinating oh!
NOOOOO!
You just showed me
what godly powers I could've had! Also you inserted something into my brain which compromised my funkin ability.
But oh that was good! Ah that was so good!
That was really really really good!
The music, the art style, the game feel, puzzles, the uniqueness of it. Ah it was good
Okay, well that was apparently just a demo oh
Man, oh, that's so cool, though.
That's so cool. That's really cool. So I don't know much about this game. This demo is free
I want to find out more about it. If I do, I'll put a link in the description below. This is a cool game!
It's just really really cool! I love seeing creative stuff like this. The art
was adorable, the music was really immersive, and the gameplay was really fun
It was fun, and it taught it very well
So thank you everybody so much for watching. If you want to play this for yourself
I'll put a link in the description below, and I if I find anything else I'll put that there as well.
Let me know what you thought down  in the comments below. Did you enjoy it?
Is this a cool game or am I just stupid? Those are not mutually exclusive questions.
So thank you everybody again, and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-byeeee!
* Outro - Crazy La Paint by Minimusicman*